[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein grundrezept von murat
und auch von vielen anderen zuschauern
ich werde heute cookies machen und zwar
mit chip cookies diese riesen coupés die
amerikanischen die außen schön knusprig
und innen richtig schön weich und immer
sagt eigentlich dazu welche cookies die
kennt ihr wahrscheinlich auch von subway
und auch von vielen anderen
amerikanischen konzernen die kopie ist
sind wirklich wunderschön
also ich find die echt cool vor allem so
schön hand groß man kann vielleicht
immer nur einen essen weil man dann
danach opfert ist aber die wirklich
richtig cool ich zeige euch jetzt mal
einfach die zutaten
ich mache jetzt mit schokoladen drops
aber ihr könnt zum beispiel auch ein
paar nüsse mit reingeben cacau
cranberries oder was auch immer für die
cookies traurig 250 g weiche butter 200
gramm zucker etwas vanille extrakt und
eine prise salz 100 gramm braunem zucker
2 eier 400 gramm mehl jeweils einen
teelöffel backpulver und natron und 200
gramm backfest eshops die zutaten müssen
alle zimmer warm sein damit der teig
schön homogen wird also dass er sich
schön verbindet es gebe jetzt zuerst
einmal die butter in denen die
rührschüssel ihr könnt das ganze aber
auch zum beispiel mit einem handgerät
berühren dann zucker braunem zucker
den nehme ich jetzt weil er einfach so
ein bisschen karamell ich und malt sich
schmeckt ob man den extrakt natürlich
und der pressesaal und die zutaten
werden jetzt für etwa vier bis fünf
minuten sehr cremig verrührt
sobald die butterlager schön cremig ist
gebe ich jetzt noch die eier
nacheinander so damit ist hier schon
mehl backpulver und natur kommt dass
hier mit dazu und das soll dann auch nur
noch ganz kurz eingehoben werden
[Musik]
zum schluss kommen jetzt noch die schoko
druck sein
das habe ich hier mein back lay und da
gebe ich jetzt die folie drauf und kann
jetzt den teig funktionieren das geht am
besten mit einem eis funktionäre hat man
einfach immer die exakt gleiche menge
und die cookies werden auch richtig
schön rund und je nachdem wie groß
später die koki sein soll nehmen wir
später auch die entsprechende größe des
eisbergs denn hier hat jetzt fünf
zentimeter im durchmesser das heißt es
werden wirklich große cookies und die
setzt sich jetzt hier drauf immer mit
viel abstand und dann werden sie nur
ganz ganz leicht flach gedrückt und dann
laufen sie im ofen noch ein bisschen
auseinander
[Musik]
und wenn ihr möchtet das obendrauf auch
noch ein paar schoko drucks zu sehen
sind
dann nehmt einfach ein paar und steckte
nach oben rein
[Musik]
und so kommt setzt den vorgeheizten
backofen bei 170 grad ober unterhitze
etwa elf bis zwölf minuten
ich muss einfach darauf achten dass der
rand ein bisschen brauchen wird aber
nicht so sehr denn dann trocknen sie aus
und werden nicht so schön weil die
cookies sind jetzt fertig ich hab sie
komplett auf dem backpapier abkühlen
lassen denn wenn sie frisch aus dem ofen
kommen sind sie noch ganz weich und
zerbrechlich deswegen ziehe ich sie mal
ganz behutsam von blecher runter mit dem
backpapier und lasst sie komplett
abkühlen
hier sind jetzt die fertigen cookies und
die werden jetzt nochmal eingepackt denn
dann werden sie einfach noch mal ein
bisschen weicher jetzt am anfang sind
sie noch ein bisschen knuspriger aber
trotzdem ihnen schon richtig schön weich
und morastig da also es kann etwas jetzt
tun soll ich probieren erklärt worden
[Musik]
das würde also falls ihr auch diese
cookies nachmachen voltaire hat gesehen
wir sind wirklich gar nicht so schwer
dann schaut auf meinem blog vorbei
dallas - blog.de und ich freue mich
schon auf eure bilder und wir sehen uns
beim nächsten mal wieder bist dann jetzt
ein cookie ein glas milch und dann
selbst für mich gewesen
[Musik]